We're asked to arrange the
following measurements in order
from smallest to largest.
And we have the measurements,
and they're different units.
This is in decameters,
then we have meters,
then we have millimeters,
then we have centimeters.
So the way I would
tackle this is
I would try to convert them
all to the same units, maybe
meters, and then compare
them all in terms of meters.
So let's do that.
So this is just a screenshot of
that exact same screen we just
saw there.
And so let's just convert
each of these into meters.
So the first one we have right
over here is one decameter.
So we have to remind ourselves
what deca even means.
Well, deca is
equal to 10 meters.
And actually, let me
add more of these,
just so that we know all
the different prefixes
we could have.
So you have deca.
You have hecto,
which would be 100.
You have kilo, which
would be 1,000.
And then, of course,
you just have meters,
and you'd have no prefix there.
That would just
be equal 1 if you
have no prefix in
front of the meters.
And then if you have
a tenth of a meter,
that is decimeter,
so this is 1/10.
Then you have centi,
which is 1/100.
And then you have milli,
which is equal to 1/1,000.
So let's use this
information right over here
to figure out how many
meters each of these are.
So one decameter-- we
just saw deca means 10.
That's 1 times 10 meters.
So this is going to
be equal to 10 meters.
So this right over
here is 10 meters.
This is already
written in meters.
This is 13 meters.
Then we have 15,000 millimeters,
but milli means 1/1,000,
So it's 15,000 times
1/1,000 of a meter.
So each millimeter is
You could view this as instead
of writing a milli here,
I wrote 1/1,000.
So 15,000 times 1/1,000, that's
just going to give me 15.
So this is going
to be 15 meters.
So this is 15 meters.
Another way of thinking
about it is, look,
1,000 millimeters
is equal to a meter.
So let's divide this
into groups of 1,000.
Well, this is literally
15 groups of 1,000.
This is 15 groups of
1,000 millimeters,
so that's going to be 15 meters.
And then, finally, we
have 1,900 centimeters.
So 1,900, instead
of writing centi,
I'm going to write
1/100 of a meter.
Well, 1,900 times
1 over 100 is 19,
so this is equal to 19 meters.
Another way of
thinking about it is,
this is 19 groups
of 100 centimeters,
and 100 centimeters
is equal to a meter.
This is 19 meters
right over here.
So let's go back to
the actual problem.
So let's remind ourselves.
This right over here,
this is 10 meters.
This is 13 meters, so 10, 13.
This right over
here was 15 meters,
and this right over
here was 19 meters.
So actually, the order that they
already gave it to us in, we
could obviously swap things
around if we wanted to.
But the order that
they already gave it to
was the order from
smallest to largest.
This is 10 meters, 13 meters,
15 meters, and 19 meters.